it has the grace of a Benigni sculpture
and contours that could have been carved
by Michelangelo the bit cerini 5300 GT
has classic Italian styling written all
over it
but for its actual creator this sports
car wasn't just about its captivating
looks it bears the hallmark of Giotto
bit Cellini arguably the most talented
racing car constructor of the 1960s the
5300 GTS mission was to leave the
competition in the dust on the racetrack
and fill its creator with pride bit
Cellini the very name still makes
Ferrari or Maserati owners nervous its
maker had high hopes of it becoming the
new star on the sports car horizon
following triumphs on the track but this
supernova on four wheels fizzled out all
too rapidly today most people wouldn't
even recognize a 5,300 GT Eric Oswalt is
the happy owner of one of these rare
racers the 5300 GT was built between
1964 and 68 and a limited-edition
according to some sources production
amounted to just 70 and assembled
specimens
Giotto bit cerini was born in Livorno in
1926 he is considered one of the most
influential constructors in the history
of motorsports he spent five years at
Ferrari as developer designer test
driver and chief engineer among his
accomplishments they're the iconic GTO
eventually there was a clash of egos
between him and boss Enzo Ferrari
leading to his departure
the GTO went on to clock up a string of
victories and remains one of the most
viable and hotly desired racing cars of
all time
for some people the greatest Ferrari
ever models have been auctioned for up
to thirty million dollars only 39 were
built
back to Giotto pizza weenie after being
recruited by Renzo revolta
he created the ESO grief Oh a
high-performance Gran Turismo with
American engineering on board
but bits Irini wanted more he built a
two-seater competition car based on the
grief oh his boss revolta wanted to sell
cars rather than burn money on the
racetrack however the two likewise
parted ways bit cerini took his latest
creation with him and named it the bits
arena 5300 GT the v8 engine was like
that in the grief Oh taken from the
Chevrolet Corvette
until anybody Pizza Rini was the first
to come up with a front mid-engine
explains proud owner Eric engines on top
of the axle have a far higher center of
gravity an engine below and behind the
axle is far lower which gives you a
massive advantage in terms of handling
it's still copied today I think for
Texas red of what is the old computer
it's a little falafel from the very
start of his career when he was making
bigger cars Ben Shalini had a preference
for high-capacity American engines over
there smaller high powered Italian
rivals he also once tried to convince
Ferrari to construct a large
displacement engine with lower rev
levels like the train together it's also
construe the 5.4 liter v8 complemented
by a battery of twin Weber carburetors
pumps out 360 horsepower and that's in
the basic version
the engine is unusually far back the
only access to the distributor cap was
via an opening on the dashboard
take to the wheel of a bit cerini and
you're left in no doubt that it was
constructed for the track the
full-blooded v8 propelling a two-seater
weighing just 1100 kilos delivers the
kind of ferociousness otherwise
associated with modern super sports cars
the GT is not meant for a jaunt in the
countryside
the 5300 GT was launched into action on
the track against Ferrari to give bits
of any revenge for his dismissal by his
former employer and he did win a few
times at the 1000 kilometer race at
Monza 1965 for example the 5300 GT left
all the GTOs in its tracks
but the car maker was unable to follow
up on that success not least because of
a lack of funds
Eric Oswald's prized beauty is the first
of just ten korzha editions featuring a
lightweight body
until he needs it cerini what with this
car which previously had an aluminum
body to a boat constructor in Italy
together they build a fiberglass body it
cerini then made nine more courses about
Anton don't know no invite three cores
I'll skip out
today the 5300 GT is a member of a very
exclusive club anyone who owns one will
be desperate to hold on to it potential
buyers are looking at a six-figure price
tag whatever condition it's in most
recently a 5,300 GT changed hands for
over half a million euros for the vast
majority of auto aficionados a bit
cerini will always be just a dream